bonjour je veux parler aujourd'hui si
c'est ce type comme moi je veux quand
des avec vous au sujet de la mentalité
ma mentalité de croissance la mentalité
perfectible
c'est à dire comment l'attitude que nous
avons notre état d'esprit et commence à
nous des finances tant que personne qui
veut apprendre
souvent les gens me disent à steve tu es
doué pour les langues
tu as la chance moi j'aimerais bien
prendre les langues mais je suis pas du
tout doux et c est moi j'accepte pas 7,7
postulat que certains gens sont pas
doués pour les langues
il ya peut-être des différences mais je
veux que je n'en toujours est vous dites
ça toi tu dis ça mais est-ce que tu as
mis autant d'efforts dans
l'apprentissage des langues que moi j'ai
émis est ce qu est ce que tu as essayé
de travailler aussi fort que moi pour
apprendre une langue et la plupart des
cas ces non évidemment et je donne aussi
l'exemple par exemple de pays comme la
suède ou singapour ou ethiopie où la
plupart des gens sont au moins biren ben
ce n'est pas que ce n'est pas parce que
dans ces pays là tout le monde est doué
pour les langues il doit y avoir une
autre explication
et je crois que cette explication c'est
que c'est une question de mentalité et
il y a eu des recherches et je vais
mettre les liens là des liens cette
recherche qui a été fait et qui
démontrent qu'ils à 2-2 mentalité deux
états d'esprit vis-à-vis l'apprentissage
les uns pensent qu' on est soit doué
intelligent ou non et les autres m
un défi parce que tout est possible je
peux le faire même si c'est difficile et
les gens qui pensent qu'ils ont je crois
et madame mademoiselle dweik appelle ça
soit une mentalité fixe vous soit une
mentalité de père perfectible et les
élèves
on peut faire des choses pour encourager
justement les gens à penser à leurs
possibilités et d'ailleurs j'ai reçu un
email
mon fils est un peu ce qui m'a stimulé à
faire sur cette vidéo
emma mon fils m'a envoyé un e-mail avec
une article qui avait été écrit un
article écrit par salma cannes 0 kas est
un titre l'américain fantastique qui a
créé un tas de cours qui sont
téléchargeables gratuitement de
l'internet je vais laisser le lien est
bien lui dis pourquoi jamais je dirai à
mon fils il est intelligent parce que il
faut pas dire aux gens qu'ils sont
intelligents il faut pas mettre l'accent
sur soi l'intelligence ou la menthe et
intelligence il faut encourager en cours
à lille et les gens quand il ya eu un
défi et quand ils ont travaillé fort et
que là ils ont surmonté les obstacles
c'est parce que c'est en apprenant c'est
en faisant de l'effort en faisant des
fautes et c'est comme ça que on élargit
on développe notre capacité
d'apprentissage y inclut notre capacité
d'apprendre les langues et donc mais
bien sûr il suffit
bon il ya la motivation on essaie
d'apprendre quelque chose et plus c'est
difficile plus il y à de la résistance
bah plus on est apte à abandonner c'est
pour ça que moi quand je prends les
langues
je fais des choses que j'aime faire donc
je ne vais pas passer beaucoup de temps
à dire des explications de grammaire à
faire des tests etc
je vais essayer de lire et d'écouter des
choses que je trouve intéressant donc si
ce sont des choses intéressent
même si c'est difficile je continue si
par exemple souvent dans l'est dans les
livres de texte l'enseignant veulent
commencer par des par exemple des
commandes ya des des contes pour les
enfants
bah c'est pas intéressant ça j'aime pas
ça tout de suite non ou bien beaucoup de
choses sur b les festivals et les trucs
de culture qui m'intéresse pas du tout
c'était important pour moi de pouvoir
choisir ce qui m'intéresse il
d'apprendre à partir de ces textes que
j'écoute que je lis et c'est si c'était
intéressant ça me motive
6 si je suis motivé je suis motivé
surmonter les obstacles
même si je fais des fautes même si je
comprends pas même si j'oublie les mots
je continue et c'est en oubliant et en
faisant des fautes et en en faisant face
à ces difficultés que mon cerveau et ma
capacité d'apprendre se développent et
donc c'est ce que l'on appelle et là
vous pouvez googlé soit en français
cette mentalité perfectible ou bien en
harley goss mindset il à vous allez voir
un tas d'articles sur ce sujet donc bon
l'important le message ici il faut pas
comme a dit enfin salman khan dans son
article il ne dira jamais en son fils
qu'il est intelligent et d'autant plus
on ne dirait pas à son fils qui n'est
pas intelligent il ne faut pas parler de
l'intelligence il faut encourager les
gens est soi même de faire face à des
obstacles des problèmes et les surmonter
et en ce faisant on développe son
cerveau et under développe la capacité
d'apprendre et bien que moi puisque je
parle 15 membres plus ou moins bien
ben j devrait développer la capacité
d'apprendre énorme il faut faire dans
celui qui ne parle de larbi ben ça sera
un peuple
difficile mais c'est uniquement un
faisan d'efforts et on espère que c'est
en faisant des jauzion qui sont quand
même intéressant et qu'on peut
graduellement petit à petit développer
ses capacités et développer non
seulement sont sur l'habileté sûr c'est
qu'à part capacité de parler ou de
comprendre la langue en question mais
aussi développer ses capacités
d'apprendre les langues
voilà c'est tout ce que j'avais à dire
merci au revoir